Well, you can see that negative 2.59 is less than the z critical negative 1.96
at the alpha level of 0.05. Since its in this critical region, we can say that
it is unlikely to have gotten a mean engagement score of 7.13. However, this
mean engagement score does fall in the critical region. However, there is
evidence that my singing made students less engaged. Perhaps I should just
stick to talking when I teach a lesson. And we can also say that a mean
engagement score of 7.13 is significant at probably less then 0.05. The
probability of getting an egagement score this far from the mean in either
direction is less than 0.05. That's basically what that means when we do a 2
tailed test. So let's say we got a sample mean that is about here. When we
determine whether or not this sample mean is significant at 0.05. We want to
know if a probability of obtaining a sample mean this far from the mean of
means is less than 0.05. And it doesn't matter what direction. So if we have
this z score, the probability of getting a z score that far below or above the
mean is the area here and here.